Jhansi McGinley big-time actor and he
stars in Stan on IFC it stand against
evil season two debuts November 1st on
IFC it's great to finally have you in
great to have you on the show we've been
trying to do this for a while we're big
fans and obviously as you humbly pointed
out you're really never out of work
you've been you've been working for a
long long time and you've been a star
for a long time as you said pretty lucky
yeah I got out of NYU grad in 84 I think
I'm about four or five years either I
think I'm a little two years younger
than you you were class of 74 yeah in
high school I was class of 78 and so I
was reading your bio I didn't realize
you did FM you were spinning at them
discs for yeah three or four years wait
did you do research on me before you
came in yeah of course oh okay yeah I
love I mean I listen to every morning
but I was like I wonder what Dana's
backstory is no I love music love it
it's that's where would you put petty in
your top five I'm just gonna grace him
in to top five mmm he wouldn't be in my
top five he is today but underrated Kim
and Bob Seger underrated agreed you know
and I tell people I even say this to my
kids and my daughter finally saw agreed
on Eddie at Red Rocks this year yeah and
she she even thanked me this morning she
said thank God I got a chance to see him
but petty at 66 and you know sort of in
that same wheelhouse of wanting to be
the next Dylan or they having that sound
and then being in the Traveling Wilburys
don't sleep on the Traveling Wilburys
yeah it was great to put Jeff Lynn in
there with George Harrison you got Dylan
coming in and Roy Orbison and Roy
Orbison taking it over top yeah it's
pretty good
but what petty did you know there's
certain guys who did it in a way that
you know you're not sure if they would
have been swallowed up by MTV or like
petty couldn't exist today the way we
are with music because I don't think we
care as much about the sound and song
there is a phenomenal very long I saw a
documentary on Netflix like yeah oh yeah
there's like three and a half hours it's
like the Eagles won that Eagles won
which is about four hours long yeah and
worth it
the the petty ones worth it who's your
favorite artist Bruce
oh well your Jersey yeah okay you have
you met Bruce I have not what I have not
nor will I in this I'm going to
comic-con tomorrow to promote the show
and I guess his show opens up here in a
second or two on Broadway yes and I got
no juice
I got no Duckett's Pauly bring out Bruce
Springsteen for John McKinley here I
tell me about Stan against evil here man
against evil is a is Archie Bunker
fighting witches and I'm Archie Bunker
got the left and it's created by one of
the big guns in the Simpsons writing
room Dana Gould and so it's very
subversive the the hero is in total
antihero all he wants to do a mission I
gave him the first year while all these
witches are invading him is he just
wants to be in his chair with about 20
beers watching The History Channel and
so whenever he's not in his chair with
20 beers watching The History Channel
he's in the wrong place at the wrong
time doing the wrong thing and so we
encounter as a witch he takes a pipe and
bashes it over the head what else he
gonna do he's Archie Bunker fighting
witches Archie Bunker couldn't be made
all in the family couldn't be made known
right I don't know I I had I on my
bucket list of people a couple of weeks
ago while promoting the show I got to do
Norman Lear's pod and what I'm brilliant
ahead of his time 93 years old sharpest
attack and I told him that I borrowed
liberally from the sensibilities of
Carroll O'Connor's character and he was
flattered and then he told me some
different inside scoops about what they
were doing and for entertainment and and
movie geeks and TV geeks like myself it
that rated thrilling but also the
Jefferson I mean they come on this was
in the 70s what they were talking about
they were talking about race and you
know had Archie Bunker was that guy in
the neighborhood that would say what he
felt right and so they knew where he
stood with everything so to Stan and so
we borrowed that very much from the
Archie archetype Stan on IFC stand
against evil season two Davey
November 1st on IFC if you stopped on
the street but what's the first question
it comes up when I am stopped on the
street yeah depends demographically
because scrubs is on your TV show TV all
day every day
scrubs comes up office space comes up
sometimes set it off comes up the rock
comes up platoon comes up Wall Street
comes up and so and I'm fine with all
that water like of course but office
space is one of those that did you know
what you had and then it became so no no
no it was a really good script Mike
judge who directed it and wrote it sent
these it's a only way this auditions
ever happened before he sent these 30
second animated clips of the characters
to you before you came in and ordered
animated yes and so everyone came in to
read for Garry Cole's role since the
Bob's really weren't on the page much
and so everyone auditioned for Gary's
role
Lumbergh and then you were sent on your
way and then they called back and said
do you want to play one of the Bob's and
I said it's largely not on the page and
Mike said we you can do whatever you
want and I'm a big fan of that and so I
went down to Austin I'd wardrobe Tuesday
was shot Wednesday and Thursday and I
was wrapped and gone Friday I was only
shot that thing for two days it's just
that one interior whether you're
interviews on and then once out on the
floor but mostly we got to pretty much
just riff paulie's got the quote we
always quote you from office space like
whenever we have an employee who's not
really up to stuff we always go what
would you say it's the pause lick your
lips oh yeah you do hear I can't do you
it that's the one we always use and then
you and then the the quote from Wall
Street to Oh whenever we would go to a
Knick six and want to see the next yeah
that was good gig I was doing talk radio
at night up at the public and I was kind
of living the New York actors dream I
was in a hit play up at the Shakespeare
Festival with Eric Bogosian doing talk
radio and for 12 hours during the day
Charlie and I were down towards the
Woolworth Building shooting
that was as good as and then at at 6:45
seven o'clock a teamster would take me
up to up Lafayette to the public and we
do talk radio but you knew Wall Street
was big because she had Michael Douglas
in it and at the time
sure Michael was huge yeah Wall Street
was yes they were movement yes but to
your first question about office space
the funniest thing about office space is
that I went to the cast and crew
screening and it was hilarious and
people were laughing and then office
space was released back when people used
to look in the newspaper at a full-page
ad for what was planed down at the
Cineplex Odeon yeah and the some genius
in marketing covered the guy with the
stapler in post-its well if you cover
somebody in yellow post-its they look
like big bird so it looked like an
r-rated Big Bird movie so nobody went it
was a dog with fleas tanked nice move
although I would go see an r-rated Big
Bird movie I think did you see what you
could pull off nobody else did you've
been you work with Oliver Stone what six
movies I have okay
the difference in Oliver Stone and
somebody else is what the biggest thing
Oliver's creative you know the the
blinders the Kentucky Derby horses here
that's tantamount to Oliver's creative
vision and if you can his visions here
on the set of what we're gonna do today
and if you can fit in that it's nirvana
but you have to see what he's seeing
though if you if you did your homework
and you brought your a-game from what
you and Oliver spoke about and you want
to fit inside here it's heaven now when
people want to function outside of it is
where you hear all the nightmare stories
like Alec came down and joined us on
talk radio and he was doing working girl
concurrently with Mike Nichols and so we
were down in Dallas and they were up in
Queens and he was commuting back and
forth and a couple of times he and
Oliver just got after it what do you
mean
arguing matches on the set knows Alec
wanted to function someplace else I
could see those two going toe-to-toe a
little bit it wasn't boring hey can you
stick around I'm going
I want to ask you some sports stuff also
when you get the role in platoon you
sort of look around and take inventory
there of who's in platoon and it's good
in retrospect it's good at the at the
when it happened it that was it was much
ado about nothing we'll take a break
we'll come back Jhansi mckinley by the
way it's IFC stand against evil season 2
debuts November 1st on IFC this is the
Dan Patrick show you get cast in platoon
any idea how old were you when you got
cast so in 1984 I was 24 ok then it's
pushed two years I was cast as Tom
Barringer's radioman third guy in the
left and then it gets canceled it's not
going to be shot in the wilds of Mexico
it gets pushed the money falls out and
then the money comes back in and now
we're going to Manila two years later
Oliver calls up and says McKinley do you
wanna play surgeon who knew you and I
was doing Hamlet at the time with Kevin
Kline at the public and no one in their
right mind would ever burn that bridge
at the public once you got in that
fraternity sorority you stayed in it
because Joe Papp used to feed on the
from the same ensemble and so I went to
meet mr. Papp and I asked him permission
to go and do this movie and he said yes
and he was good to his word he would
hire me again several times but the
minute I left there Marcos wouldn't
leave the Philippines and there was a
revolution so we were postponed six
months the play opened it was the most
important Hamlet on these shores
what was it like when you saw that movie
on the big screen it was the best thing
I'd ever seen
because I was at the Ziegfeld remember
that yeah they had the coup yes 54
Lathan cool speakers yeah that would go
the the helicopters would go past you
yeah and I thought it was the best thing
I've ever seen and what I mean is that
when you read a script usually that's as
good as it's gonna get because you see
it in your brain and there's no
compromises yet and when I saw it up at
the Ziegfeld what Oliver did I thought
it was twice as good as the script and
that's impossible
you're in Point Break we love Point
Break we've had you know Reeves soon to
talk about Point Break but now you're
the FBI boss by him but he wasn't the
first guy that was gonna play that role
no when we were in the Philippines
Charlie was offered it it was called
Johnny Utah at the time so Charlie Sheen
was so offered at first Johnny Depp was
offered it and I don't know who else but
which is not unusual as films get pushed
yeah John Spencer was playing originally
cast as sergeant O'Neill in platoon and
then John got a play on Broadway and he
did that instead of this low-budget
independent in the Philippines and
anybody would have done that Broadway
play but why why this point when Point
Break comes on we watch it like it's one
of those I know I think I know why it's
interesting because Kathryn Bigelow
directed it and it's an exploration of
testosterone and the thrill directed by
a woman so Kathryn gives it this little
twist in what whatever her her view of
is she did it in in Baghdad with the
bomb The Hurt Locker The Hurt Locker she
didn't there to that that there's this
female perspective which is twice as
interesting as if you know Bob Smith did
it you're uh are you diehard New York
Yankee Nick Ranger fan is that how it
works
yes you know my grant my grandfather
played for the 1927 New York Giants and
he's in the College Football Hall of
Fame and his plaque down in Atlanta now
his plaque says he was the original
wedge buster so he was just the
hard-headed Irish jackass who'd come
running down the field that all of I
doubt 180 and just explode into people
at the University of Pennsylvania he was
a two-time all-american and then the
giants the giants offered him a contract
and so he had three jobs in Philadelphia
and he would commute to up to New York
on Thursdays he was a an assistant coach
at st. Joe's he worked at the beneficial
Bank and he did something else and up on
Thursdays he'd go up in practice and
then they plans to play football yes
would you rather be an athlete or an
actor actor yeah no interest in that you
know massive interest but it just it
doesn't what those guys do is is what
you did at Dayton is the stuff of course
absolutely it's
let Julie John most of us can't do that
yeah wait you didn't do that good at
research you were to realize that didn't
do anything really a date me but but
thank you John
you're saying all the rage that one
night where you had 36 points I know
that was Clinton Massey I owned them
just got accepted in your high school
Hall of Fame I know all about you damn
boy yeah yeah yeah maybe you should
interview me John I've I'd love to the
show is a stand against evil it's on IFC
it's season two debuting November 1st on
IFC I love scrubs and I got into scrubs
late my son and daughter said you would
love this show and I remember I watched
the first episode and I went how did I
miss this like if scrubs would be a
perfect show to debut on Netflix or
Amazon or Hulu now and people would eat
it up not that they didn't or don't but
that's how we consume TV what was it
about scrubs that just somehow made it
stand out make it work I think just like
we were talking about Norman Lear
earlier that in in TV in episodic
television where there's 22 episodes
there has to be some central figure in
the engine-room who's driving it and for
us it was his guy bill Lawrence who's
just a monster in that discipline he's
just he's top of the pyramid for his
group he's the Norman Lear of his
generation and we have the next version
of that on stand against evil in Dana
Gould the guy who was in a Simpsons
writing room and you have to have that
man or woman driving the thing otherwise
you're dead meat because there's two
writers rooms there's two groups of
seven everybody was an editor at the
Lampoon at Harvard everybody is the
smartest guy in the room but you need
somebody to corral all these brains and
stylistically and tone wise put
everybody in the same direction was
their storyline on Scrubs that almost
didn't make it I don't know on 9/11 or
happened our second or second week back
in after the pilot shoot the pilot in
March and then you get picked up and
then we went to work in September end of
August and that second week Sean Hayes
came in and visit us as a guest star and
that that one almost didn't come
together it
everybody was pretty shattered but there
it was so snarky like there was so it
was like a story within a story within a
story almost it felt like yeah I think I
think again tone wise what Billy was
able to do was to make it snarky but
then all of a sudden there was a there
was a heart thing in there too and that
could just destroy you you said driving
in that you you heard something in my
voice when you've fallen into this
rhythm where just like in back to office
space what Gary Cole did an office space
a couple of times with some of the some
of the fellas you gave him this routine
yeah and I have to do that now as we say
goodbye to John seem again link stand
against Yvonne I MC John thank you for
joining us my plugin the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience